sin duda lo ocurrieron en el 2014
cuando ocurrió el euro magna y la caída
de víctor yanukóvich que era pro moscú
hubo un intento de víctor yanukóvich
porque hay que explicar este detalle que
es importante de forjar algunas alianzas
comerciales y económicas con el bloque
europeo de colonia europea toda la
presión que el kremlin hizo para que
yanukóvich chino no hiciera eso era con
la idea de mejorar la situación
diaria de los de los ucranianos que en
realidad no estaba bien entonces el tema
de la pobreza que ha venido creciendo en
ucrania y sobre todo también los índices
de corrupción que han sido bastante
altos si no me equivoco ucrania está
ocupando un puesto de 137
con problemas de digamos de corrupción
muy muy fuertes pues prácticamente le
permiten a vladimir putin considerar una
serie de factores y de variables que
obviamente jamás pueden ser el pretexto
propicio para una invasión y entonces
empieza pues desde 2014 hasta la fecha
al llevar a cabo todo el forcejeo que
había estado viniendo haciendo hasta que
viene el tema de la invasión
en estos días entonces incluso la
atención de todos sabemos que la
atención que arranca desde diciembre del
año pasado hasta la hasta la hasta este
momento que es lo que deriva
desafortunadamente con la con la
invasión y bueno definitivamente sigue
por si ya habían problemas económicos de
hecho de ucrania ahora esta invasión
militar pues va a suponer
desafortunadamente una desmejora de la
economía ucraniana en consecuencia lo
que muchas veces no se toca porque es
muy fácil hablar por ejemplo de
geopolítica de política internacional de
de todo el tema militar del curso de la
guerra en este momento pero bueno no
estamos hablando tampoco de
toda la consecuencia humanitaria que
esto puede llegar a tener y un país que
desafortunadamente se suma a otra lista
de países que en los últimos 20 años han
caído una condición de país de estados
fallidos como el caso de libia el caso
de siria irak y también pues
recientemente todo el fiasco de
afganistán